[Music]
what's up guys I'm be showing you how to
kill brew black dragons with an
alternative account this is my other
account that I'm going to be using with
me and so what you're going to need what
I have is I have the guff exploit amulet
of glory gun fix dragon hide graphic
ethics chaps holy sandals because like
spray serving of doing if I want to come
back the grand exchange anti Dragon
shield rune crossbow and Ava's
accumulator and then I have for prayer
pots my normally use three and a half or
three depending so just to be safe
extend the anti fire rainy potion to
monk fish and then assign the potion for
when I run there so you want to teleport
to draynor village then you want to run
over here
or you also need diamond bolts II so
what I would highly recommend is you
have at least eighty range because I try
doing this with 75 range and it was
extremely slow and not really worth it
so I'd recommend 80 range cuz I do with
80 range and make plenty of money and
film super fast so some of the rare
drops that black dragons can grow up big
and drought dragon full helms which at
the moment or worse let's see
with 14 mil they also drop visages which
it worth almost 10 mil but typically
they drop threats during my stamina
potion so you want to run down here in
port sound
there's
correct
you
I'm from here in a run West for a while
brutal black dragons great afk we can
good
run we're running to here so we can get
into for the jugular
you
if you have higher prayer or higher
range obviously this isn't a very good
business for a bit someone that's just
starting with 80 range in just this 43
prayer just has typical gear
so you're going to want to investigate
statute
and make sure to set up your your your
quick prayers to have the magic thing
case of the magic protection protect for
magic ending it will run over here north
there's some hellhounds on here
links on you want to protect you one
keep reading
you
there's gonna be some dragon on a
potential dog let's on this way
then directly noises the black dragons
CP portal
you
run right here and then when they spawn
a target
so you're sit here in a clock it
and drink your random potion and your
Santa fire and then just kill it and now
you can afk just make sure to watch your
prayer and now this is where your alt
account comes so this is where having an
alternative account comes into play well
you have your one count killing the
Dragons you have the other one so
instead I'm going to right here we're
going to run up to right where is it
right here where the rope spot is where
you can come up when you're done killing
dragons and then we already have our
gear to give to our player other player
so we're going to give them give our
other account for prayer pots too we
have two random postures in case we need
them we have extent Anton fire and then
a monkfish case needs it so each time
the other player comes up your other
player comes up you'll trade all the
bones and drops you get from the dragon
and then give it to your other account
and then that way you won't have to Bank
you can just bank on this count and keep
killing kills keep killing dragons so
show you when I get there so while your
other account is coming dragons you want
to go right here this spot right here
right where that guy came out there's a
hole that you can't see unless you go up
the road while you're telling the black
dragon and your other account while
they're killing black dragons when it
gets a full load it comes up here then
you're going to trade them all this gear
and he's going to trade you all the
shade yourself all the drops you got so
that way you can save it and go bank it
really quick and then give up to join so
I'll show you when I get down with the
load I wasn't recording but I just got a
dragon plate skirt and that's worse the
186 K so I mean I'm telling you guys
it's a great money-making method
especially you have another count just
to give the gear so I'll be back when
I'm below the most on okay now I've
basically got a full load so I'm going
to run up to the rope I'm going to trade
my other account give the four
pots on rainin potion and then I'm going
to trade over these all stuff I don't
use all stuff I don't need
except except now I go back down
and then when this dragon appears I'll
take it
and then I start the cycle again now
whether your other account is attacking
dragon still you're going to run down
here to the bank there's a bank down
here to the southwest and then you're
going to Bank all the stuff they gave
you and get new gear so Bank it all
right here cup for prayer pots an anti
fire a monkfish and then run back and
that's how you complete one load really
quickly okay so I'll do this for an hour
and I'll show you guys how much money I
make I'll be right back
alright so I'm at 56 minutes and I won't
be able to get another kill within that
time frame
so I'm going to go ahead and leave at 55
minutes can go for a full hour because
I'm taking too long and then I'm going
to go ahead and teleport both these
accounts to the grant exchange
be right back with the loot and now I
will sell everything and we'll see how
much money you should hinton sell
everything because I don't want to wait
so you probably could make a little bit
more money than what I make that okay
you
five hundred thirty five k we're going
to have to - about what the supplies I
use to probably use about eleven prior
products I'll probably use about all
this stuff
so we'll - 130 K so 400 so you can make
about 400 K in an hour with very low
stats just 80 range whoops is wrong
account but 80 range on my other account
and just using the account to trade over
gear over and over so I just decided to
do another hour just to see how much my
head make and I'm about 54 minutes and
I'm almost done and I think I'll finish
just under an hour and then also
everything and I'll show you guys would
happen alright so I finished with 57
minutes so just an hour an hour and I'll
go sell stuff and I'll show you guys
what I get alright this is what I got
and I charged over from my other account
so about six on ok let's go ahead and
sell it and let's see what we make
alright so I made about 600 k 597 9x2
so we'll go ahead and - about 100 K from
that that it takes in supplies
so that's about 500k an hour so you can
make anywhere between four hundred five
minute an hour just as a low-level
counsel thanks for watching guys 52 next
video